20:18 is shaping up to be an intense
year at the Cineplex with numerous
superhero movies Star Wars and Harry
Potter spin-offs all on the horizon but
for every film worth getting excited
about there's another that we're
absolutely dreading from sequels and
reboots that nobody asked for to
biblical B movies and poorly timed
Horrors we're betting that the following
films will be the worst of the worst in
2018 Woody Woodpecker if you're a fan of
the classic Woody Woodpecker cartoons
you'll definitely want to give the
upcoming live-action hybrid from
Universal of wide berth --mess
family-friendly adaptation of the
screwball tune pits a CGI Woody
Woodpecker against a big city lawyer who
intends to tear down his woodland home
to create space for a new development
Woody decides to take matters into his
own hands and violently defends his home
against the construction crew taking
snaps on his smartphone as he does the
trailer is truly the stuff of nightmares
the whole thing is clearly meant to be
cheap and cheery but in the end it comes
off as just cheap with the character so
poorly rendered in CG that his presence
is completely jarring bizarrely the film
is already a hit in Brazil were an early
release and explicably grossed more than
6.5 million dollars
go figure Samson the faith-based
production company behind the god's not
dead trilogy are back with an all-new
biblical blockbuster this year bringing
the tale of Samson to the big screen
pure flicks has been making inroads in
the Christian market over the past few
years thanks largely to the success of
their family friendly home streaming
service which offers gems like the Jeff
Foxworthy hosted the American Bible
challenge chief executive Greg goo Dorf
told the New York Times we've been
blessed with really strong growth our
god-given dream was to provide content
on a consistent basis to be an
alternative to what Hollywood was
putting out well the god's not dead
films didn't require much in the way of
visual effects samson relies on them
heavily and the lack of funding is
highlighted by the substandard cgi
according to the bible story the hebrew
strongman fought his way through 1,000
philistines with an animal bone and beat
up a lion with his bare hands all of
which is included in the trailer sadly
the effects on show in these vivid
amoment see
pretty dated the whole thing looks like
it was put together using deleted scenes
from The Mummy Returns add in some Billy
Zane in the toy crown and you've got
what looks to be a cinematic failure of
biblical proportions never really
understood what that meant Teen Titans
go to the movies Cartoon Network's Teen
Titans go has divided DC fans since it
started airing in 2013 many viewers are
of the opinion that the show was an
insult to both the original Teen Titans
animated series and a much-loved comics
of the same name some have even
petitioned the network to cancel Teen
Titans go citing the bad messages it
sends to young viewers and the fact that
it more or less ignores the source
material we polished Paulding goofing
around and being silly wrong on this
mission co-producer Michael jellinek
told comics Alliance that he's well
aware of the internet hate even though
it's never slowed him down he and his
team have managed to thrash out over 200
episodes in just four years but the move
to the big screen will likely prove to
be a step too far
Teen Titans go to the movies will follow
Robin Starfire cyborg Raven and Beast
Boy to Hollywood as they go in search of
a director to make them famous with the
very own superhero movie an idea that
probably would have worked better as a
double episode rather than a full-length
feature film unfortunately kids will
probably clamor to pay for an hour and a
half of the same stuff everybody hates
about the show Slender Man in 2009 a
Something Awful user posted a made-up
horror story and some doctored photos to
the websites forum unaware of the chain
of events he'd set in motion before long
the faceless man heat created with the
ability to turn children against one
another have become a genuinely popular
meme and tragically would go on to
inspire a real-life crime unsurprisingly
people have reacted angrily to the news
of a Slender Man movie even if it wasn't
a totally insensitive move by the studio
Sony still wouldn't be coming out of
this well because the trailer makes the
movie looked downright awful from
creaking doors and jerking heads to
creepy forests and screaming schoolgirls
they break out every worn-out trope a
horror fan could think of and then some
if you want to be scared this year
you're better off looking just about
anywhere else
Elita battle angel Robert Rodriguez
changed the way indie filmmakers thought
about CGI when he created the stunning
visuals in 2005 Sin City from his home
studio faithfully adapting Frank
Miller's beloved graphic novels the
director has taken similar approach to
the upcoming Alita battle angel his
live-action take on the manga battle
angel Elita the cyborg heroine is being
played via motion captured by Rosa
Salazar whose eyes have been enlarged to
look as though they're straight out of
the pages of the comic talking about the
bizarre concept Robert Rodriguez said
the early artwork I saw the James
Cameron had before it was even
technically possible had that in her it
was so striking and so arresting I
thought my god we have to do that we
have to be the first to bring a true
manga and anime character to life the
eyes are the window to the soul
got some big windows to see him plot of
the soul that goes on within that
characters the character has such great
heart and great soul while the
filmmakers intentions might have been
good fans of the source material haven't
been as positive about the design
decisions considering the sordid history
of live-action manga adaptations we're
not holding on to a lot of hope for this
one Peter Rabbit while it's now
considered a classic of children's
literature British author Beatrix Potter
actually had trouble getting the Tale of
Peter Rabbit published when she wrote
and illustrated it in the late 1800s in
1901 she decided to self-publish 250
copies of the book with her own money it
went on to become a hit the award amount
prompting one of the publishing houses
who previously turned her down to come
crawling back in the years that followed
hunter turned down plenty of offers to
turn Peter Rabbit into a feature film
even rejecting offers for an adaptation
by Walt Disney himself we'll never know
what Disney's Peter Rabbit might have
looked like but it's probably safe to
say that Potter would have hated the
brash party animal that Sony has turned
him into Potter's relative Nadine
Hanwell told the Scottish Mail on Sunday
Beatrix Potter would be turning in her
grave
I hope parents don't take their children
to see the film she would absolutely
loathe this reviews don't get much worse
than that but it looks like there's a
good reason for the hate Peter was
always mischievious in the books but in
this interpretation he's less cuddly
critter and more arrogant frat boy you
must be big
that's right judging by the early
reaction to the trailer this one is
likely to be another major miss for Sony
Hotel Transylvania 3 summer vacation
like the majority of Adam Sandler films
2012's Hotel Transylvania went down
pretty badly with the critics only
managing to score 44 percent on Rotten
Tomatoes predictably reviews for the
2014 sequel didn't fare much better
after that flop most people probably
expected the franchise to crawl back
into its coffin why don't you just put a
stake through my heart so why are we
staring down the barrel of a third Hotel
Transylvania movie basically because
they make a ton of money the first two
films were made for around 85 million
dollars each yet they pulled in
staggering amounts at the worldwide box
office 358 million dollars and four
hundred and seventy three million
dollars respectively a series of leaked
emails in 2014
confirmed that Sandler in the studio had
fallen out over Hotel Transylvania 2
with the star apparently wrestling
control of the animated project away
from director Guidry Tartakovsky despite
that giant mess Sandler Tartakovsky and
Sony all came back together to make a
third Hotel Transylvania putting
financial gain over a professional pride
we can probably expect summer vacation
to be the worst Hotel Transylvania yet
Fifty Shades freed mocking the terrible
dialogue littered throughout the Fifty
Shades of Grey novels was the Internet's
favorite game for a while and it's hard
to argue against the haters when you
actually sit down to read the books he
grabs me suddenly and Yanks me up
against him one hand at my back holding
me to him and the other hand oh my god
I'm not gonna say that to be fair to
author EL James she spotted a gap in the
literary market and plugged it so to
speak
cleverly tweaking what began as a bunch
of Twilight fan fiction for the mom
audience a big-screen adaptation seemed
inevitable after the success of the
raunchy trilogy and there were more than
a few fans who hoped that the books
kinks would be ironed out in the process
it hasn't happened seriously yes
reviews for the first movie bashed
almost everything about it and the
second picture went down just as poorly
judging by the trailer for the final
installment Fifty Shades freed
filmmakers haven't changed their
approach one bit yeah it'll probably
rake in just as much money as the first
two installments in the trilogy but that
doesn't mean it'll be a pleasure to
watch vitu journey to China this
adventure fantasy sequel pits action
stars Jackie Chan and Arnold
Schwarzenegger against one another in
Russian and Arne is Captain Hook
yes confused well to properly explain
this wacky looking russo-chinese
production we need to first mention that
the previous movie V for bid and Empire
was the highest-grossing Russian film of
2014 the swashbuckling fantasy epic is
based on a classic horror novella first
published in 1853 and the movie was even
on track for a US release until a
lawsuit between co-producers derailed it
that may have been for the better
considering that the few of American
critics that actually got to see it
court exactly blown away but considering
how much money the first film made a
sequel was inevitable only instead of
concentrating on the positive parts of
the original they seemed to have embrace
the crazy Chan and Schwarzenegger take
top billing over the film's original
star Jason Fleming they both appear more
than him in the trailers even though
they're only supporting characters in
the continuation of his tale the first
film was guilty of favoring style over
substance and that doesn't seem to have
changed in the sequel thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]